[MUSIC]
The Board of Trustees and the faculty of
Carnegie Mellon University, together with
the staff, students, alumni, and friends
of the university are convened here today,
October 26, 2018, to celebrate the history
and traditions of our institution
and to look forward with the inauguration
of the tenth president of
Carnegie Mellon University, Dr.
Farnam Jahanian.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Ladies and gentlemen, please rise for
the National Anthem, sung by alumnus Corey Cott, accompanied by Professor Gary Kline.
[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Wow, that was great.
Thank you, Corey.
How about a round of applause for a Tartan.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I'm getting a sign.
Please be seated.
Good morning and welcome, everyone.
>> Good morning.
Farnam, I don't know about you, but
it feels good to be here this morning,
doesn't it?
How about that.
A wonderful place to be this morning.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you all for
being part of this wonderous celebration
of a transformative moment in CMU's
history and pivotal time for humanity.
The digitilization of information and
the democratization of knowledge and
the unprecedented access to data and
analytics are driving societal
change at a spectacular pace.
The scope, scale, and
ubiquity of these technologies
are revolutionizing every
sector of our economy
including finance,
healthcare, transportation,
energy, manufacturing,
education, and yes, the arts.
The trail blazing work of our faculty and
students has position CMU at
the leading edge of human progress.
There's never been a more exciting time to
engage in research and work that matters.
The potential for profound impact is
extraordinary and we at CMU have a long
tradition of excellence in our bold
visual arts, music, and theater programs
and we continue to define and
manage the space where our humanity
intersects with technology.
CMU not only embraces the new
paradigms we define them.
Our university recruits diverse
perspectives and ideas
to advance human knowledge and
pursue new modes of human expression.
Here at CMU we dismantle the silos
restricting forward momentum
and we help people from all
walks of life to succeed.
When we consider ideas from
across the grand spectrum
in a culture of civil discourse,
we all win.
The things that make our community unique
have never been more
valuable than they are now.
Now the future of education
in the 21st century
will depend upon breaking
down disciplinary silos.
It will be forged by diverse minds coming
together in learning and research.
As an institution grounded in
relentless creativity and
driven by fearless entrepreneurial spirit,
Carnegie Mellon University knows
how to do this better than anyone.
Education is the key to staying
ahead of the fast moving current.
To make the most of opportunities that
lie ahead, we must be willing to disrupt
the system of higher education itself,
and to do that we need a bold leader.
The single greatest responsibility of
our Board of trustees, thank you so
many of you for being here, is to select
a president who can guide our university.
Dr. Farnam Jahanian is the right
leader at the right time
to guide our great university forward.
A prominent scientist,
creative entrepreneur, public servant and
esteemed educator, Farnam Jahanian
brings the experience, passion, and
leadership necessary to steer CMU.
Each of us has a role in his
success here as we charge in with
the fantastic work of magnifying the
societal impact of scientific discovery
emphasizing our leadership and
creative expression and
building the skills students need for
a lifetime of learning.
I ask all of you, and each of you,
to join me in supporting him, in his
efforts, to meet this strategic vision.
Now, it's a great honor for me to
introduce one of our university professors
who are the most, one of our most
senior members of our faculty.
Dr. Marlene Berman, who is the Thomas
X. Stockton Baker University Professor
of Cognitive Neuroscience and
the first CMU woman elected to
the National Academy of Sciences.
Marlene.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Here's Marlene.
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Good morning.
It is a true privilege for me to
participate in this investiture ceremony.
I came to CMU in 1993, expecting
that my sojourn in Pittsburgh
would last just a couple of years.
This year marks my 25th anniversary.
Even after trying to move to
Toronto to be closer to my
family in 2006,
CMU exerted its magnetic pull and
drew our family back
after a brief six months.
I've served under three
previous presidents at CMU
and am delighted to join you
in welcoming the University's
tenth President, Dr. Farnam Jahanian.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I also take much pleasure in welcoming Dr. Jahanian's wife, Tris,
whom I have come to know
over these past few years,
as well as all the members
of the Jahanian family.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I am truly honored to have been
chosen as a speaker for
this august ceremony and
am unreservedly supportive of Dr.
Jahanian.
I have witnessed him close up in
action over the last four years and
have observed his gracious behavior,
even on those occasions when
I've been a thorn in his side.
Particularly remarkable is that Dr.
Jahanian takes time
to listen to the multiple
constituencies that make up CMU.
I served as a co-chair of the task force
to enhance the students' experience.
As provost, he not only initiated this
task force, but he remains supportive and
involved in its work even when
he was no longer provost.
Stepping back,
I am struck by how CMU has evolved
since my first year here way back in 1993.
It is truly staggering.
Some of this evolution is
a result of the expansion and
growth of the physical
setting of the campus and
the recruitment of outstanding new
faculty, staff and importantly, students.
But this evolution is reaping the benefits
of hard work done over generations
to build CMU as an educational and
research powerhouse.
And as links in the chain
of this ongoing community,
we have all forged a common bond
with a perpetual commitment
to improve the students' experience,
to enhance the educational opportunities,
to engage our alumni and
to conduct cutting edge research
that makes a difference to our society and
our world.
I'd like to share with you a comment
made to me a couple of weeks ago.
I was having lunch with a junior in
mechanical engineering, Alex Markowitz,
and in discussing CMU, he said,
it just does not get better than this.
And he is right.
My personal commitment to
the institution is clear, too.
My husband, David Plaut,
who is also a faculty member here, and
I, have entrusted CMU with
the education of our own children.
It just does not get better than this.
We're a CMU family through and through.
And so, as we begin this new
chapter in the evolving
book of Carnegie Mellon University,
my colleagues and I dedicate ourselves
to continue building an institution
of the very highest caliber
with a commitment to an inclusive and
equitable campus for
all of its members and
with opportunities for
all to realize their educational and
research potential.
Dr. Jahanian has clearly expressed his
commitment to facilitating
these initiatives
and we are all so
excited to see what comes next.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Now, I am pleased to welcome to
the podium, Dr. Ramayya Krishnan,
Dean of the Heinz College of
Information Systems and Public Policy.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you, Marlene.
Good morning, I'm delighted to
introduce our next speaker,
Keith Block,
is a great friend of mine personally, but
also a great friend of the university and
of the Heinz College.
Keith is a distinguished
alumnus of the Heinz College,
a member of my Deans Advisory Council,
and a member of the Board of Trustees.
He's also co-CEO of Salesforce and
member of their board of directors.
Keith serves and
has served a number of important roles.
He's served as the company's vice-chairman,
president and
as a director since joining
the company in June 2013
and additionally served as the company's
chief operating officer since
February 2016 - clearly a multidimensional,
multi-talented person.
As President and COO of Salesforce, Keith
oversaw the company's multi-billion dollar
global sales and services business,
alliances and channels, industry strategy,
corporate development, corporate affairs,
marketing and business operations.
In February 2018,
Keith and his wife Suzanne
established the Block Center for
Technology and Society at CMU.
This important center, which is cross-cutting and university-wide will foster
critical dialog on campus to create
inclusive and meaningful plans
of action on topics, such as a future to
work and issues of trust and transparency
in the use of autonomous systems to
improve the quality of life for all.
Keith holds a Master of Science
Degree in Management and
Policy Analysis from the Heinz College and
a Bachelor Degree in Information
Systems from Dietrich College.
So he was ahead even then at being at
this nexus of technology in society.
In addition to his membership on
the Carnegie Mellon University Board of
Trustees, he's also currently a member of
the World Economic Forum's Information
Technology Community as a governor and
on the advisory board of
our Heinz College and
its Board of Trustees
of the Concord Museum.
Please join me in welcoming
Keith Block to the podium.
Keith.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Well, thank you, Krishnan.
You've made me blush this morning,
so I appreciate that
and thank you very much for
that very kind introduction.
So first, I want to say, good morning
everybody.
>> Good morning.
>> Okay, that was my best Farnam.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I gave it a run, my friend.
Anyway, good morning to everybody,
faculty,
alumni, staff, family and friends.
It is an honor to be here today to
celebrate the investiture of a great man,
Dr. Farnam Jahanian, as president
of Carnegie Mellon University.
In all of life's endeavors, Farnam
has led with a tremendous spirit and
an unrivaled dedication.
Whether as a world-renowned
computer scientist, a passionate,
successful entrepreneur,
a tireless public servant or
a world-class leader in higher education.
And, oh by the way, just an incredible,
incredible human being.
Now, I've had the opportunity to
work very closely with Farnam.
and we have shared many
experiences around career and
our life journeys, including
everybody's favorite, parenthood.
And Farnam, by the way, that advice you
gave me about curfews for teenage kids,
thank you so much for that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I would never
I would never have thought of that myself.
>> [COUGH] But thank goodness it worked.
Over the years, we've had a very,
very close relationship and friendship
and for that I'm very, very grateful.
Professionally, I've also had
the opportunity to observe Farnam in his
influence in guiding policy
at the World Economic Forum.
And I will tell all of you,
he has represented this
university incredibly well.
I've also witnessed his leadership here
at CMU personally, with students and
faculty and staff, and
members of the Board of Trustees
and whether it's uniting the community
to support the Special Olympics,
where I understand he as a passion for
dunk tanks -
>> [LAUGH]
>> Do you just wanna come up and
tell everybody about this dunk tank?
All right,
I'm sure you'll get to that at some point.
- or really fostering engagement between
students from different colleges, Farnam
has a talent, a true talent for bringing
people together and breaking down walls.
Farnam is also a leader with impeccable
integrity and the highest of character.
He conducts himself with grace, and
dignity, and thoughtfulness, and warmth.
There is no question,
no question Farnam will guide this
institution into the future and
accelerate its impact on the world.
So today,
we witness the passing of the torch
to an incredibly talented individual.
Now, this torch has been held by many,
many great leaders throughout
Carnegie Mellon's very rich history
and there have been so
many accomplishments and so
many historic milestones.
Since Andrew Carnegie founded
a technical school in 1900,
individuals of great character and
honor have taken the reigns of leadership
of this very prestigious institution
and each of them have led with courage and vision.
Names like Hamerschlag, Doherty, Stever,
Cyert, Cohon, those are but a few.
Each of these presidents and others of
this storied institution led through
myriad chapters of American history,
world history, the turn of the century,
the Great Depression, the explosion of
technology that Jim was talking about just
a few minutes ago,
civil unrest, war and peace.
And throughout all of this,
presidents of Carnegie Mellon
have guided this institution to
the forefront of educational excellence
and they have shaped the minds of so
many young people.
All the while ensuring that the university
remained a source of inspiration,
a guiding light, a beacon of hope.
And now we pass this
torch to Farnam Jahanian.
There is no one who is better suited
to lead us into the next chapter
and this next chapter is
arguably the most important ever.
For we do live in very,
very interesting times.
We have seen, and
this is just the beginning,
but we have seen incredible
advances in technology.
We are at the dawn of a new era.
Some refer to it as
the Fourth Industrial Revolution.
And this is where we have the convergence,
the perfect storm of social, and mobile,
and deep learning, and artificial
intelligence, and 3D printing, and
amazing technologies all brought
together to drive incredible innovation.
Now, like many of you,
I have the opportunity and
good fortune to speak with other CEOs and
world leaders.
And what is top of mind in that group
is how to harness this wave of
innovation in a very positive way.
This convergence of technology is
having a profound impact on our world.
We see it in our daily lives.
It has also brought great disruption and
given rise to many, many questions.
What will these new technologies be?
Will they be positive for mankind?
What are the socioeconomic effects?
What are the privacy implications?
What will be the regulatory issues?
What will be the future of work?
And Farnam is passionate about these
questions and even more passionate
about CMU leading the way to drive
those answers to these questions.
These are all important issues of our time
that we have to consider in a thoughtful,
and meaningful, and measured way.
We are clearly at an inflection point.
These advances must be for good.
They must enlighten, they must empower,
and they must take humanity
to greater heights
and in a world where there is
an ever increasing divide,
these advances must create opportunity for
all, not just a few, so
that all of mankind can participate and
contribute.
Now, this will take vigilance.
It will take dedication and
it will take leadership.
And this is why the faculty,
the staff, the students,
this community at Carnegie Mellon are so
critical to the future of this nation,
this society, this world.
For the young minds that we shape
here have an important mission.
They will go forth into the world
with the knowledge, the vision, and
the ethics that Carnegie Mellon
has instilled in them.
And they will go forward into the world
to solve universal issues that lie at the
intersection of technology and humanity.
The graduates of CMU must be equipped to
thrive and lead in a world of uncertainty.
For these are truly uncertain times.
Today, the value of trust is
being questioned more than ever.
Trust in technology, trust in our
institutions, trust in our leaders.
Some would say there is a crisis of trust
and this crisis of trust has
created a leadership void.
And now individuals, and
companies, and faculty, and
students alike must fill this breach
and it will be the graduates of CMU that
will answer this call for leadership
and for them, it is a call to arms.
It is a call to arms for us all.
It is an obligation to
lead in an ethical and
transparent way,
to engage in constructive civil discourse,
where disagreements will arise
and that's okay, but
dialogue must happen with respect,
and while there can be differing opinions,
there cannot be differing facts,
and, most important, most important,
to restore trust in our society,
because without trust, we have nothing.
It will be the graduates of Carnegie
Mellon that will be called upon to
cultivate and drive a culture of
success in business and society,
where the core tenants of diversity, empathy, equality, humanity,
accountability, and opportunity for
all are at the forefront.
Never before has this institution
been more important to the world.
Never before has leadership at the
intersection of technology, and society
and humanity been as
critical as it is right now.
And though the future is unwritten I
am very confident, very confident that
the graduates at CMU will be the authors
of a great future for all of us.
Now, as we stand at
the doorstep of this new world,
the dawn of a new era,
we need a truly special leader.
To help guide and
shape the lives of those who will
determine the future, all of our futures
and never before has a presidency
of this institution been
as important as it is right now
and it requires a remarkable leader,
a truly outstanding human being, and
that person is Dr. Farnam Jahanian.
We stand with Farnam today,
as he takes his rightful place amongst
the great presidents of Carnegie Mellon.
I cannot imagine a better leader
who embodies the values of CMU.
I cannot imagine a better leader with
as much vision, with as much passion,
with as much focus
and I cannot imagine a better leader and
torch-bearer of this great institution.
Farnam, we are very lucky to have you.
You are the right leader,
as Jim says, at the right time.
So ladies and gentlemen, please join me
in congratulating a true friend, a great
leader, and the next President of Carnegie
Mellon University, Dr. Farnam Jahanian.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ladies and
gentleman, please welcome Professor
Gary Kline, and alumna, Tamara Tunie
accompanied by the School of Drama choir
performing, "How Can I Keep from Singing".
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]
>>[APPLAUSE]
>>Wow. That is a miracle. Tamara, thank you so much.
That was just - the choir is absolutely spectacular.
Thank you, thank you.
Another round of applause.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Gary Kline. Gary Kline,
thank you so much.
I mean, when someone shows up with a mace,
it takes the fun out of the meeting,
usually.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I have to say that it's just a,
that is just wonderful.
Thank you, thank you so much.
At this time, I would like to welcome
to the stage, Dr. Rebecca Doerge.
The Glen de Vries Dean of the Mellon,
College of Science.
Ladies and gentlemen, Dean Rebecca Doerge.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you Jim.
It is my pleasure to
introduce Martha Pollack.
Dr. Pollack is the 14th
president of Cornell University.
As faculty at the University of Michigan,
Dr. Pollack and
Dr Jahanian forged a strong friendship.
I'm pretty sure that neither of them
imagined that they would be here today as
president of two of the best
universities in the United States.
[LAUGH] Their presidencies come at
an important time in history, when we're
presented with new opportunities and
challenges on a daily basis.
Technology is moving
forward at an amazing pace.
It's impacting all areas of research,
transforming how we teach and
blending the lines between disciplines.
Doctors Jahanian and Pollack are the right
time of leader at the right time, bold,
innovative, forward thinking.
We need to make our institutions
a transformational part of this time.
Since becoming the President of
Cornell University about a year and
a half ago, Dr. Pollack has demonstrated
a strong commitment to sustaining and
enhancing Cornell's academic distinction
while enhancing equality, diversity
and inclusivity.
She has supported the university's
expansion into New York City,
where it has programs that range from
architecture to technology to medicine.
Dr. Pollack came to Cornell University
from the University of Michigan,
where she was Provost and Executive
Vice President for Academic Affairs.
Before her tenure at Michigan, she served
on the University of Pittsburgh's faculty,
so welcome back to Pittsburgh.
Dr. Pollack is renowned for
her contributions in computer science and
artificial intelligence.
Her research focuses on automated
planning, temporal reasoning, and
constraint satisfaction.
She has designed intelligent technology to
assist people with cognitive impairments
and their caregivers.
Dr. Pollack has also served as
president of the Association for
the Advancement of
Artificial intelligence
and was a member of
the advisory committee for
the National Science
Foundation's Computers and
Information Science Engineering Division
and a member of the Board of Directors
of the Computing Research Association.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr Martha Pollack.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you, Rebecca.
Good morning to all of you.
I'm truly honored to be here today for the
inauguration of my colleague and friend,
Farnam Jahanian, as the tenth president
of Carnegie Mellon University.
Most of you probably don't know this,
but there's an historical
connection between Carnegie Mellon and
my own university, Cornell.
Andrew Carnegie was one of Cornell's first
trustees, elected to that role in 1890.
Later, honoring his passion for music,
Carnegie donated to Cornell a magnificent
organ to celebrate the 80th birthday of
our first president, Andrew Dixon White.
Alas, the organ suffered a ignoble fate.
It's air intake, for some inexplicable
reason, was located in the men's bathroom,
and in 1935 there was a plumbing failure
that filled that room with water.
Unaware of this, the university
organist sat down at the instrument and
according to historical account,
blew a mighty crescendo,
which filled the leather organ
pouches with water, ruining them.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Perhaps we're doing better off with
a gift of bag pipes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now,
there is also a long time
connection between Farnam and me,
although of course not as long
as between our universities.
As Rebecca said, Farnam and I met about
20 years ago when we were both faculty
members in computer science and
engineering at the University of Michigan.
I later became Chair of CSE and
Farnam succeeded me in that role.
Later, he became provost
here at Carnegie Mellon,
a few years after I had
become provost at Michigan.
And he started as interim president here,
just a couple of months after
I became Cornell's president.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> But I'm gonna take that couple of
month's head start seriously, and
imagine that he gives me the right to
offer him some advice on leadership.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Specifically, I'd like to quote Hopper,
the grasshopper in the animated movie,
A Bug's Life, who said this. [I] quote,
"the first rule of leadership,
everything is your fault."
>> [LAUGH]
>> I hate to tell you this Farnham,
but Hopper's right, especially when
you're the president of a university.
But really, having everything be
your fault is a fair trade off for
all that is wonderful about
being a university president.
It is, as I know Farnham appreciates,
a huge privilege to lead a university,
especially a great one
like Carnegie Mellon.
Universities are institutions that
are second to none in changing lives.
We change the lives of our students.
We change the lives of the communities
into which our students graduate
and we changed the lives of all those
who are touched by the research and
the scholarship of our faculty.
Farnam, I can assure you is the perfect
choice to lead Carnegie Mellon and
to ensure that it continues it's
proud tradition of changing lives for
the better.
He has a range of experience that's
an extraordinary fit for this university.
Experience in academia, where he's
been a talented and dedicated teacher,
as well as a renowned researcher who
discoveries have had broad impact.
Experience in industry where he founded
a very successful network security
start-up company.
And experience in government,
where he served in major roles at
the National Science Foundation,
the National Research
Council's Computer Science and
Telecommunications board, and more.
But beyond all that,
what I want you to know, is that Farnham
also has a set of personal characteristics
that are in complete alignment
with Carnegie Mellon's culture.
He is a person of high
integrity who values and
exhibits creativity,
innovation and entrepreneurship.
He values and promotes mentorship and
the development of
leadership skills as essential to
preparing students for today's world.
He appreciates the importance of
university supporting a breath of
intellectual inquiry,
but he also has a particular passion for
translational research that produces
results that directly benefit society.
He's focused on the ways
in which technology can enhance
all aspects of the university from
teaching to research, to operations.
A few years ago when Alan G. Merten
retired from the presidency of
George Mason University he said this.
[I] quote, "do I like being
a university president?"
I don't know.
But I do know that I have loved being
George Mason University's President.
Some of my friends
are university presidents.
I wouldn't wanna be where they are and
they probably wouldn't wanna be here.
These jobs can look a lot alike,
but they are not." End quote.
Search committees look for university
Presidents who fit their university.
And I can't imagine Carnegie Mellon
finding someone who fits better
than Farnam.
He will be a brilliant and inspired
leader for this wonderful university.
And who knows,
he may even learn to play the bagpipes.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you, President Pollock for
your thoughtful and inspiring words.
We appreciate your presence with us here today.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> My name is Jeanne VanBriesen and
the Chair of the Faculty Organization and
Educame, like company Professor of Civil
and Environmental Engineering and
Engineering in Public Policy.
I'm joined by Jessica Owens,
the Chair of Staff Council and
the Program Coordinator for
Supplemental Instruction,
an Excel Collaborative
Learning Group program.
Roshni Mehta,
the President of the Student Body and
a junior in economics in
Dietrich College and the Tepper school
and Alex DiClaudio,
the President of the Alumni Association Board,
an alumnus of Heinz and Dietrich Colleges
and the Tepper School of Business.
He also serves on our Board of Trustees.
Prominent within our university
seal is the thistle.
For more than five centuries,
the thistle has stood as the national
emblem of Scotland, the birthplace
of our founder, Andrew Carnegie.
Among the oldest still celebrated
national emblems in the world, the thistle
represents one of the highest honors an
individual can receive from the community.
Among the Scots,
it is bestowed only on those who have
made an outstanding contribution in life.
It is our distinct honor to present Dr.
Jahanian with an specially
commissioned sculpture of a thistle.
On behalf of the Carnegie Mellon
University community.  This token is meant
to serve as a reminder of the attributes
within the CMU community that thistles
are said to embody- strength,
bravery, determination, and devotion.
The first characteristic is strength.
Our strength is in the work we do and
in our approach to it that is
equal parts fearless and curious.
This strength lives in our students,
our faculty,
our staff, our alumni, our leadership
and our board of trustees.
All of our hearts are in the work.
>> The second characteristic is bravery,
we've got it.
The people who are drawn the Carnegie
Mellon view challenges not as obstacles
but as opportunities.
We inspire each other to dig in,
dive deeper, peel back the extra layer,
continually in search of breakthroughs
that will make a difference.
>> The next characteristic
is determination.
We are determined to solve the most
difficult questions posed by society.
In order to do so we use self motivation,
discipline, and multiple
opportunities to explore potential
solutions that no one has posed yet.
>> The final characteristic is devotion.
We are devoted to Carnegie Mellon.
We're devoted to its experimentation,
its rigour and
research with the human dimension
of purpose and tangible impact.
That impact is felt on campus in
Pittsburgh, throughout the nation and
across the globe.
>> President Jahanian,
can you please join us?
We hope this sculpture reminds you of
these characteristics interwoven in
the CMU community, and your leadership.
May it inspire you everyday, let it
forever commemorate and symbolize this
day as we move forward into the future
we are committed to creating together.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> What a beautiful representation
of all that is Carnegie Mellon.
Thank you so much for
sharing this beautiful community gift
on behalf of everyone at CMU, thank you.
The investiture of a president
is held as an academic ceremony
much like commencement and,
like graduation, it symbolizes an important
transition, a right of passage.
Today's ceremony is a right
of passage not only for Dr.
Jahanian, but also for Carnegie Mellon.
New leadership can inspire new thinking,
new directions and new aspirations
and I'm confident that under Dr.
Jahanian presidency,
university will take on a fresh group
of challenges and ask new questions.
Dr. Jahanian and Faculty Marshals,
will you please come forward to join me?
Farnam Jahanian, by the authority
of the Board of Trustees and
with the enthusiastic approval of
the faculty, staff, students, alumni, and
this distinguished assembly,
I present into your keeping the charter
of Carnegie Mellon university.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And I also present to you the great
seal of the university, the symbol of
the high office you now hold, and
invest you with all of the rights,
privileges, and responsibilities
of the Office of the President.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Ladies and gentlemen,
on behalf of the board of trustees and
the members of the academy, I now present
you with the 10th president of
Carnegie University, Dr. Farnam Jahanian.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you very much.
>>[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you very much.
>> Wow, Chairman Rohr,
trustees, faculty colleagues,
students, staff, alumni, and
honored guests,
good morning and thank you.
It's a great honor and
a truly humbling experience to stand
here as the tenth president of
Carnegie Mellon University.
I hereby accept the symbols,
the Office of the President, and
all of the responsibility
pertaining thereto.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> It brings me great joy to celebrate
this occasion with my family,
especially my wife,
Tris and my children,
Daniel, Thomas, and Sarah.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Who
have always been my greatest blessing.
I am so touched by the presence of
friends, former students, colleagues
and collaborators, who have traveled
from across the country to be here.
I also wanna acknowledge
community partners and
civic leaders from the Pittsburgh region,
who are showing their support for
this university today and every day
and I would especially like
to thank my dear friends,
Marlene Behrmann, Keith Block,
and Martha Pollack,
for their kind and
thoughtful words this morning.
Martha, I've been
following your footsteps.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What you didn't tell them is that you
were my department head and my provost,
my boss for many, many years.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I
don't know what you're
planning to do next.
I'm pretty happy to be here,
so don't do anything else.
>> [LAUGH]
>>[APPLAUSE]
>> Today's ceremony is a celebration
steeped in tradition,
the singing of our national anthem,
our academic regalia,
the iconic sound of bagpipes.
These rituals remind us that this moment
iss not about the beginning
of my journey as President.
Rather, this ceremony celebrates
our storied history as a community
of scholars in a nation driven
by learning and discovery.
CMU is, relatively, a young university.
We've come so far in such a short time,
and our accomplishments
would have not been possible without
the leadership of my predecessors.
I especially want to acknowledge and
thank President Emeritus Jerry Cohon
>> [APPLAUSE]
>>aAnd past Provost Mark Kamlet
>> for their
enduring commitment
to this university.
We are so grateful to you for
everything you have done for
Carnegie Mellon, Mark and Jerry.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Of course,
great leaders are inspired by
an extraordinary community.
As Mark and Jerry can attest,
countless faculty, staff, alumni
and partners help to build the foundation
of excellence CMU enjoys today.
I am grateful to all the men and
women who have guided this
university since its founding,
and who will secure its future.
In particular,
I wish to recognize the members of
Carnegie Mellon's Board of Trustees,
who are the stewards of this institution.
I am so grateful for
their trust they have placed in me.
Trustees, would you please stand to be
recognized, Carnegie Mellon trustees.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you, please be seated.
I would also like to acknowledge and
thank the university deans,
vice provost, and
executive management team,
my co-conspirators, who do so
much to advance CMU every day.
Would the university leadership
team please stand to be recognized.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Like many of us here, I left home
as a teenager to pursue an education.
As I prepared for
my journey from Iran to Texas,
I remember asking my
mother to help me pack.
She said,
pack light because what ever you need,
you will find there. Pack light because
what ever you need, you will find there.
And so as I left home with
little more than a sense
of optimism and a desire to
make the most of the incredible
opportunities that only an education
in the United States could provide,
I've carried my mother's words
with me over these many years.
I think her advice may have been based
on a hope that I would return home
once the initial excitement wore off,
but I was pretty stubborn.
In fact, I got my tenacity from her,
along with a work ethic
instilled in me by my father.
My siblings who are here
can attest to that.
But looking back, perhaps my mother
was hinting at the knowledge
I would accumulate in the journey ahead.
As a teacher and advisor,
I came to understand the incredible
power of education to change lives.
As a researcher, mentor, entrepreneur,
I observed the potential of
a single idea to launch a new enterprise
or disrupt an entire industry
and during my time in public
service in Washington,
DC, I saw how these ideas,
how the ideas emerging from higher
education serve as a foundation
of our success as a nation.
My 30-year career ultimately led me here,
to this city and this university.
This community, our community
embodies all of my most fervent
beliefs and my greatest passions.
Every day at CMU, I am inspired by you.
Here, the world's most ambitious
students collaborate at the edges and
intersection of diverse fields, and
go on to change the world as alumni.
Here, faculty leave an indelible mark
on society through their scholarship.
Here, professionals and
dedicated staff create an environment
that supports our shared success.
These are the people and the ideals that
set CMU apart from the very beginning.
When Andrew Carnegie founded the Carnegie Technical Schools to educate the sons and
daughters of factory workers in 1900.
Early, it's an evolution.
This institution would house two
great learning environments,
the College of Engineering and
the College of Fine Arts.
You see right from the start, we were
bringing together creativity and industry.
Our willingness to take risks
continued in the 20th century when
we became the first degree granting
drama institution in the United States.
And then when the Mellon Institute
of Research founded by Richard and
Andrew Mellon, merged with Carnegie Tech
to create Carnegie Mellon University.
And again, when Newell,
Simon, Perliss and
Raj Reddy came to dominate
the emerging field of computer science
and establish artificial intelligence
as the next frontier in human progress.
To paraphrase CS pioneer Grace Hopper,
the most
dangerous phrase in the English language
is we've always done it this way.
So at a time when computers
were barely understood.
We were among the very first to
recognize the power of computing and
we made some big bets.
In 1965, we established our
Department of Computer Science,
in 1979, we founded the first
Robotics Institute at the US University.
In 1984, we attracted funding
from the federal government to
launch the Software Engineering Institute.
And in 1988, we announced the first
college in the world devoted
solely to computer science.
Ours is still the model
that others follow.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> In the process,
we've created new fields of inquiry, such
as machine learning, transition design,
and the science of learning.
We've magnified our societal impact
through technologies like autonomous
vehicles and additive manufacturing.
And we did all of this while
also cleaning up at the Tonys,
the Emmys and
the Putnam competition.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> There's
a lot to be gained by
looking back at our past.
We see who we are,
who we've always been.
Alumni from those early years
would certainly see themselves
in today's students.
Entrepreneurial, creative, collaborative,
whip smart, and just a little bit quirky.
>> [LAUGH]
>> While the past has left a bright trail,
the future is arriving faster than
anyone could have predicted and
you've heard several
speakers talk about that.
Our entire world is adapting
to unprecedented advances that
are rapidly transforming our economy,
our society and our culture.
We must ask ourselves, how can higher
education fit into this dazzling future?
Indeed, our industry has
recently come under scrutiny.
This is not a new phenomenon.
Academic institutions have
often been seen as or
criticized rather as ivory towers.
But there is no doubt that sustained
investment in research and
education has fueled our nation's
broad prosperity since World War II.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Universities exemplify our faith in
the power of education to transcend
social economic and racial divides.
To reinforce our role as
pillars of progressive society,
higher education must approach our
mission with renewed attention to
the unique demands of tomorrow.
At stake is the ability of our society
to retain its fundamental commitment
to democracy, truth, equity,
and freedom of expression.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> At Carnegie Mellon,
we have always responded to challenges
with trademark fearlessness.
I'm reminded of the leadership
of Dick Cyert, who not only
pioneered a new model for business
education as dean of our business school.
But would later serve as one
the most visionary CMU presidents.
More than 40 years ago, he made bold but
calculated investments in the very
areas that define our leadership today.
These risks were not always met with
broad support, but they paid off.
As a result,
CMU grew from a small regional institution
to an international center
of higher education.
The time to be intentionally
bold is once again upon us.
We have a singular opportunity to
wield our exceptional strength
and make the next big investments
in our global leadership.
Let's consider together what society
needs most from academic institutions In
the context of our two core missions,
research and education.
At CMU, we advance human knowledge
through scholarly research and
forge new connections to our
humanity through the arts.
But the nature of research and creativity
is rapidly changing, increasingly becoming
dependent on people working across
the boundaries of established disciplines
and on computational
data-driven approaches
that are accelerating discovery and
innovation.
This is precisely where CMU excels.
In fact,
we have cultivated distinct leadership
where these two areas intersect at
the nexus of technology and society.
Through this expertise, we're enhancing
the way we live, work and communicate
and we're shaping modern culture through
visionary art, performance and design.
CMU legend Herb Simon once said,
we're not observers of the future,
we're actors,
our job is to design a sustainable and
acceptable world and bring it about.
This remains true, as true today as when
he said it more than 20 years ago.
What has also remained constant is
the tremendous responsibility that comes
with this influence.
I was reminded of this last year when I
came across an editorial by David Brooks
in the New York Times, which
reflected on Pittsburgh's Renaissance.
Of course, our connection to this
city is one of our greatest strengths.
But this article,
while acknowledging CMU's positive impact,
also warned of a so-called,
Carnegie Mellon layer of prosperity.
That had not quite penetrated
working class neighborhoods.
Indeed, we are witnessing
the disenfranchisement
of a growing segment of our population,
people who just do not see themselves
as part of this new economy,
who can't even imagine a pathway to entry.
While the nature of this divide has
been debated by pundits on the left and
on the right, this goes far beyond partisan politics.
We all bear responsibility for
ensuring that the future we
are building works for everyone.
If we succeed, the United States
will continue to serve as a shining
example of prosperity and
democracy for the rest of the world.
Here lies the greatest obligation for
institutions of higher
learning in the modern era
and a commitment that lies at
the heart of CMU's leadership.
Even as we break new ground in technology,
we must work to mitigate
any consequences that diminish
human dignity and opportunity.
That is why at CMU, scientists and
engineers work together with philosophers,
artists, economists who will
shape what might be possible,
with ethicists, humanists, and
policy experts, who will guide our path
and with the behavioral scientists
who will measure the impact of our
work on humanity.
Reinforcing our distinct strength at
the nexus of technology and humanity will
be crucial to building an extraordinary
momentum in both research and creativity.
And as president, I am committed
to supporting this leadership.
By investing in a diverse community
of faculty and researchers,
by doubling down on our partnership
beyond the borders of our campus
and by creating vibrant living
laboratories in communities around
the world.
This is the next frontier for
Carnegie Mellon and
I believe it will only deepen our
societal impact heading into the future.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> As much as we value the impact of our
research and creativity, we are equally
committed to our educational mission
and as a CMU parent,
the responsibility of preparing the next
generation is deeply personal to me.
For the CMU students, here today,
and also across various campuses and
on our campus watch parties,
you are my most important motivation.
You're spending your
most formative years here
from what I remember from
my own college experience.
You are undoubtably forming
life-long friendships.
You know, many of my best friends from college
are still my best friends today.
The foundation you built here will
sustain you as you enter a world defined
by continuous disruption.
According to a recent study, about two
thirds of jobs that you will
hold throughout your
lives do not even exist.
This reality has dramatic and
immediate implications for
the kind of education you deserve today.
Throughout our history, every period
of significant technological change
has been met with a corresponding
wave of innovation in education.
I'm here to tell you, that right now,
we are at the dawn of the next major
transformation in education
and Carnegie Mellon will be at
the forefront of these changes.
From curriculum to pedagogy,
to structure and organization,
we are re-imagining our education
with your futures in mind.
We're breaking down disciplinary silos and
launching
cross-cutting programs that better serve
your interests and societies' needs.
Programs like behavioral economics,
neuroscience and IDEATE.
We're embedding continuous learning
in the skills that will only increase
in demand as automation
reshapes the future work.
Skills like communication,
critical thinking and entrepreneurship.
We're investing in infrastructure that
supports the new ways that students learn
and collaborate,
spaces like Tepper Quad and Scott Hall.
We are utilizing our
expertise in the science of
learning to develop
a personalized model of
education focused on how
each of you learns best.
Every day we work to build and
sustain a community that's inclusive,
equitable, nurturing for
both graduate and undergraduate students.
A place where diverse perspectives
can come together in a culture of
civil discourse.
To our students, thank you for
entrusting us with this most
important chapter in your lives.
You will always be at
the heart of my presidency.
As we consider-
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> As we consider aspirations that unite
this global community,
philanthropy must continue to catalyze and
support our forward momentum.
In fact, this university was
founded by an act of philanthropy.
At this pivotal moment, I am delighted
today to announce two extraordinary
new commitments that will provide
critical resources to Carnegie Mellon.
In recent years, Carnegie Mellon has
been making significant investments for
our College of Engineering,
including a state of the art maker
ecosystem that serves the entire campus.
Today I'm pleased to announce that
the Allegheny Foundation has committed
a $30 million lead grant toward
the transformation of Scaife
Hall into a modern new home for
our Mechanical Engineering Department.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> This grant, the largest in the history
of Allegheny Foundation, will enable us to
bring our total infrastructure investments
in engineering over the last decade to
more than a quarter billion dollars.
But this commitment, CMU will be better
able to compete for best students and
faculty, driving Pittsburgh's
reputation as a hub for innovation.
We're joined today by Matt Groll,
President and
Chairman of Allegheny Foundation.
Please join me in thanking
Allegheny Foundation for
their generosity to Carnegie Mellon.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Matt, please stand to be recognized.
>> At a time when college education has
never been more important,
many prospective students and
middle class families feel
as though they're simply
priced out of education that
they may need for the future.
This is why CMU has made growing our
endowment for scholarship, fellowships,
and financial aid, one of our most
important strategic priorities.
Today I am pleased to announce
that CMU trustee Todd Johnson and
his wife Cindy have committed $50
million to create an endowment to
support undergraduate scholarship and
student success.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> You know, I made the announcement a couple of
times yesterday, and
I said this last night.
Every time I'm making this announcement
when I get to the word student,
I choke up.
That's why we're here.
Todd and Cindy will you stand
please to be recognized.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Well, I lost my place.
>> [LAUGH]
Boy, I didn't realize this
speech was this long.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I know, tell me about it.
Well,
>> [LAUGH]
>> Back to the place that I lost track
of time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This support will greatly expand our
ability to ensure that
a Carnegie Mellon education
is within the reach of
all talented students.
This gift, the largest toward scholarship
support in Carnegie Mellon's history,
was inspired by Todd's own path
to success here at CMU and
the fellowships that funded his education.
Please once again join me in thanking and
congratulating the Johnsons for their
generosity and commitment to our students.
Todd and Cindy, we are so
grateful to you for your generosity.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I hope you packed a good lunch.
This is a long speech.
My fellow Tartans.
Whether you're in Pittsburgh,
Silicon Valley,
Australia, Rwanda or Qatar,
I hope you are as excited as
I am about the future of
Carnegie Mellon University.
To be part of CMU at
this moment is to be at
the cusp of the next great phase of
societal and human development.
If we continue doing what we do today,
we'll maintain momentum and
continue to be a great university.
But if we are very intentional, if we
are unapologetically bold, and
if we are committed to taking risks.
I am confident that we
will position ourselves
among the top tier
institutions in the world.
A place that's known for writing the story of this century.
An institution dedicated
to anticipating and
solving the most pressing
challenges facing humanity.
Through creative inquiry, through
scientific discovery, through the impact
of technology and through a transformative
education that changes lives.
As we embark on this exhilarating
future together, we do so
as a community bound together
by a set of core values
that serve as our foundation.
Integrity, knowledge, compassion, respect.
The great scientist Albert Einstein
understood this fundamental connection
between excellence and human values.
In 1950 he wrote,
only morality in our actions can
give beauty and dignity to life.
To make this a living force and
bring it to clear consciousness
is perhaps the foremost task of education.
Andrew Carnegie put it
a little more simply.
My heart is in the work.
Each one of us has a role to
play in bringing beauty and
dignity to our mission.
Through the impact we make on society,
the leaders we develop and
the opportunities we create for others.
I feel privileged to work with
such outstanding partners and
I look forward to all that
we will achieve together.
Thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
I hereby declare this inauguration of the tenth president
of Carnegie Mellon University to be concluded.
The audience is requested to remain
at your seats until the completion
of the recession.
And now please rise for
the singing of the Alma Mater,
which will be sung by members
of The School of Music.
[MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE]